good afternoon and welcome again to the
Friday review of apps my name is reto
Meier and joining me in the studio I
have Trevor Jones have everyone and via
the miracle of modern technology joining
us from his new abode in New York City
we have Roman Nurik hello everyone
a Roman thank you for joining us in your
flickery self so we're going to take a
look at a few apps today and while
Himalayan tries to figure out what the
flickering is about we may start off by
having a look at Sami color so we're
also going to look at GPS test a couple
of notes apps and some exercise apps as
well run doubles so we've got quite an
interesting and eclectic collection for
you today so shall we get started
sure go ahead let's have a look at Sami
color we're gonna fire this up on the
air on the phone over here
so I'll wait until it gets a chance
excellent somehow that's me all right
perfect
so here we go so summer color by a code
carpet tapped three times to buy
interesting I wonder my alternatives are
so I can see an arrow here so I'm gonna
slap a cross and I can see a number of
different options here not entirely sure
what they okay so they're locked all
right so we'll go here and click okay
interesting so this is so in case it
wasn't obvious this is an app which is
targeted towards children right hence
the tap three times device indeed tap
three times two I hopefully a lot of
times they complained you know we hear
from people who write apps or directed
towards apps to are targeted towards
children is the you know there's these
five buttons and then children to go and
hit on them accidentally so I like that
yeah if you like you couldn't go and
mash on the screen so anything to go and
prevent them from accidentally buying is
probably a good thing absolutely
although I wonder I wonder if you want
to go a step further and actually hide
that behind a menu option or something
like that yeah still probably ready to
actually go all the way in a cuter on
the pin locking marker but yes that's
that's a very good point but still it's
it's that's a good point you make
alright so the idea here is that we can
color in
the little guy on screen using the
colors at our disposal become green ears
there actually are more colors there are
more colors oh look at that
I can swipe to get more colors you might
want to figure that out I mean they
didn't do a I'm there to go and show you
there's more pages but that's true I -
all the noise of all the colors it's
actually really easy to miss it didn't
occur to me that the that the page it
was responding about the colors
themselves that's interesting so okay so
what I would say is you know
particularly for something it's also a
minute here by the way I saw it does
have the menu not that menu ah it's a
little black thing right it's a menu
that's interesting so two points here
first is uh we just roll up slightly
menu button of shame because it's there
but doesn't do anything especially
especially because it doesn't know
anything there's really no reason to
have that exactly so that's that's the
big hype we have for the menu button
being there as if it doesn't actually do
anything
Oh even if it still does something you
shouldn't have it anymore that's true
yeah that is right there there is no
excuse for having a menu button at this
point yeah I think we've gone I think
we've moved on far enough now I don't
mean oh it's yes now our second release
where the menu button Oh
if you can't pay you go I'm thoroughly
swear menu button is deprecated so yeah
at this point we really shouldn't be
seeing that anymore me exactly so yeah
that would be step one is remove that
menu button out having the little eyes
that's is interesting now nothing's on
so you actually drag it oh you can click
as well click target doesn't seem to be
working a hundred percent of the time so
that's a bit of feedback but yes it also
works the dragging is quite nice now the
other thing that confuse me too now that
back button what do you think that's
back oh that's a good question
it's just above the other back button I
would probably think undo it doesn't do
well it took me I was like what's gonna
happen when I push this button yeah
definitely anything which looks like a
back button I think you're kind of
taking your usability into your own
hands here cuz you suddenly go oh is
this gonna exit no clearly kids aren't
gonna I think that but they're probably
not also knocking I think they might
they might get the regular back button
things undo that's a good point
particularly once you've made it
ambiguous here that maybe back means
undo you probably want to simplify that
so I don't think this is discoverable at
all
never have occurred to me to press the
googly eyes now in fairness a
six-year-old probably would think to hit
pretty much everything on screen so that
would help but yes there's multi-level
undo but this is a children's app so
yeah exactly but that would be nice and
particularly like so once you hit undo
having that stay on screen so that you
can do multi-level undo it would be nice
but I mean maybe maybe have these as
have as an action bar along the top
might be might be interesting I guess
you want to keep the screen clutter down
you don't want to have people
accidentally pressing buttons so having
it hidden in a ways is useful but okay I
mean there's an argument that the kids
are gonna match everything in the screen
so I can sort of see the argument for
hiding it but I think the
discoverability can really be improved
yeah what do you think Raymond do you
have a from a usability perspective an
idea here of how you can maybe make
these more or less obvious yeah so I
mean I think the first thing is that I
mean asking its Discoverer slidy things
like sliding drawers that's I think it's
asking a little too much and you know in
general we we recommend using gestures
to you know to uncover things sliding
drawers I personally am kind of against
but you know using gestures is normally
okay like you know paging between
screens and things like that but for
kids you know kids kind of they
understand you know simple gestures like
you know like sliding but as the new
really really really obvious I don't
think it is obvious in this case what
I'd probably do instead is really just
put it on screen and you know for things
like back for things like you know
navigating to other pieces of art it's
actually like right now once you're in a
in and drawing there's no real way to
get to other drawings so for that you
may want to use gestures like maybe
slide left to kind of go back to the top
level screen but you know sliding up a
thing to reveal actions or or even at
the very bottom something as simple as
using a view pager to slide between
different colors even that may be a
little too on obvious in that case maybe
just have you know left and right
buttons yeah well there's already
trained people who didn't notice that
you could type the colors
that's that's actually that gesture that
you described is what I assume did the
page it was for was that if I started
swiping left or right it would take me
to a different region so that's why the
visual cue wasn't obvious to me that it
was I think just like in general when
dealing with kids apps you want to put
more stuff in a fun like friendly like
picture form on screen rather than rely
on gestures too much so I think in this
case kids may get confused oh how do I
give back its whatever and obviously you
know grown-ups will know that oh you
press the back button stand read back
button but kids aren't as you know
they're not as used to using smartphones
so don't assume that standard kind of
Android patterns applied kids yeah I
think that's particularly true because
while it's good that the book is a
consistent approach to using the pager
and having you know I'm quite a fan of
having this indicator to show you what
page you're on they use it sort of to
mean different things on different pages
I managed to exit there were people so
that's another tip if I exit from a from
a particular drawing so if I exit from
from here by hitting back when I reload
the app I should go back to that to the
same place that was because the chances
of someone actually particularly kid
accidentally hitting back and being like
oh I've lost everything
is high but yeah so the views that I
peer to page between pictures and once
you go in they use it to page between
colors which i think is somewhat
confusing particularly because this
isn't is it a proper pager I guess it is
it's showing showing a set of different
colors each time but yeah having that
the same visual metaphor meaning two
different things can be a little bit
confusing yeah well you may want to do
is when having lots of colors I mean in
this case there's lots and lots of
colors there's lots of choose from you
may want to just have like when you
touch the color it expands up this
larger palette to choose from and or
something even like you know have them
smaller so that you can hear the kick
can just drag their finger around look
at this massive collect at the bottom
and it shows them a preview of what
color their fingers are almost like a
magnifying glass that may make a little
more sense than kind of swiping left and
right yeah I think so too
otherwise it's I really like the
simplicity of the app so it's
you know there's no ambiguity as to what
you need to do how it's going to work
you get the immediate you know benefit
you hit the screen and things start to
happen which is really nice pictures are
nice cutesy otherwise yeah I think it's
quite a nice app otherwise there's a one
more thing I wanted to add place on this
is one part of the app I think you might
be the page where the teacher is
standing up looking at a chalkboard and
it's a bunch of different shapes there
yes so you're just basically freeform
you just draw creeper oh really
huh in that case what I would ah nice so
you should probably support multi-touch
there kids love like placing all their
fingers all at once in this payment
actually I'd like that a step further
even and trying to take pressure yes so
there's actually an open-source app
called markers that was recently
released by a daniel-san lab who's in
the interpret team and that shows how to
do like all sorts of crazy pressure
sensitivity and as well as multi-touch
so this is on normal screen it's just a
normal capacitive screen you can
actually still get to some pressure data
so you know it's not the same as you
know like your your your Wacom tablet
where you have you know 500 levels of
pressure sensitivity but you know if
it's good enough to get you in ICU I
yeah that's also you can even consider
having a single just like massive like
take over the entire screen and just
give like kids a playground to just
bring on nightly just before I'm drawing
booty not like or sex or anything just
just give them a giant canvas drawing
yeah absolutely I don't get more obvious
to because it would never have occurred
to me that if I hit one of the three
objects on the on the right here that
that would mean that I get freeform
drawing whereas that would seem like one
of the you know something which you
would in particular want to be able to
do it's locked it's locked yeah of
course
why isn't it working which is another
tip as well so obviously you've got the
icon on the bottom which says locked
which to most adults should be pretty
obvious but I missed it which is
probably more of a reflection on me than
on your app but that'd be like brilliant
you just cover the terror screen because
you can't hear anything there yeah
exactly
you've already go sort of the partial
opacity
you can make that so you can see through
it a little bit more but cover the
entire screen or when I when I press it
display a toast or something saying this
is locked you know purchase it from the
home screen something like that because
again it's not obvious like I know that
when you first start up the app you see
the instructions for how to purchase
yeah I like that you like you tell if
you tap the lock thing it should you
know fade out and like say you know
purchase from home screen and lock go
come back word some some way to live
yeah absolutely absolutely which is and
you'll notice that I find the navigation
slightly tricky but otherwise yeah
otherwise it's it's it's definitely a
good idea and it's nicely implemented
you know just to go along further from
what Trevor was saying it might be nice
to have a little bit more animation a
bit more dynamic mess ISM within the app
yeah maybe some subtle things like this
guy there could be like maybe tapping
his foot or yeah yeah
so something again make it feel like
you're just not staring at a static
image absolutely yeah I think some some
really subtle animations could make a
really big difference it's just you know
it will attract your attention it will
make your eye focus on different parts
of it would be quite interesting yeah or
yeah since there's an app designed for
kids you can even have like you know a
little Easter eggs you know like you
tamio like they I think going over here
right there's the background maybe you
know if this wasn't locked if I tapped
on this guy maybe you know you start
moving or a sound you play right so
something people want make kids want to
go and explore a bit mmm absolutely
absolutely and it it's it's kind of nice
that all of the discovery things like
the freeform drawing is all you know
totally you know you play with the app
and you discover these things which is
kind of nice but it would also be
perhaps useful in terms of getting
people to use the app in the first place
to give some more indication and what
some of those Easter eggs are are some
of the things that you can do like maybe
you know tutorial or something at the
beginning which just has you you know
forces you through basically the three
different modes you press the colors to
draw here you get freeform and now we
give you these sort of worksheets we can
do what you want to do nice alright any
other any other comments Trevor
Robin I think they would I wanted to say
two quick things you know were running
running high on sounds but do quick
things about the market or started that
who will play listing all right that
should pull it up here let's see what we
can do yeah um it's a very quick
feedback but yeah search for a fest you
can almost again the barcode on our
screen in here I probably could
it's uh my apps probably faster okay
real good yep so a couple of very two
very quick things in the feature graphic
you have the name of the app Samuel
colors the font size is really really
small at the top and so one thing to
notice that on in the Play Store on
devices iPhones you're going to see the
feature graphic compressed to a really
small size so you're not going able to
read that text so if you can find some
way to bump up the font size so that
it's a little more obvious you know what
the name of the app is they'll be much
better because there are cases where the
feature graphic is used not adjacent to
the name of media the second thing was
around screenshots your screenshots are
actually using the device frame
generator
I would probably avoid using device
frames in your screenshots themselves
yeah Skol yeah because when you open it
up on a phone you've got a frame within
your phone the same frame as the phone
you're using we must go deeper yeah it's
a good point it because it looks great
when I bring them up full screen like
this actually looks pretty cool although
it is kind of inception II but when
you're just looking at them in the
carousel it looks kind of weird because
you just got like a bunch of phones
side-by-side yeah yeah yeah those frames
are I think more for use on webpages
things like that marketing material not
Suren
yeah I mean your playlist is marketing
material and sense but solutely not
confuse them there yeah it's good to see
as well it's been translated into German
Japanese Korean and Spanish and giving
them there's not actually a lot of text
that seems like a really good way of
being able to create a better experience
for your users make it more discoverable
in google play at a relatively small
cost and it's very well received
it's average reviews in market so well
done
hopefully few of those tips which we've
given you will will help to to make your
app even better okay oh that's alive
hard to say
all right we're going to assume we're
alive our confidence monitors have
disappeared and right now this is what
I'm gonna dropped off the Hangout
because that computer is taking a tumble
but are we otherwise online in and what
you can see excellent we all switch on
the HTML box down there I think we lost
that signal above the attack okay well
let's put all that out we will continue
you guys want to do next we're gonna
have a look at GPS test plus I think
okay so this is a ApS testing app so
this is interesting I'm going to presume
that it's using some of the more
advanced geo well I guess GPS functions
a location-based service functions which
you can actually get you a lot of
information about the the way in which
the location-based services are using
satellite information to to be able to
figure out what your location is sadly
we're probably not going to be able to
see it in here with a ceiling above our
heads wow that's true but still well
that's true okay so we've got zeroing
view zero in use right now so your
accuracy is that's okay you can still
see useful exactly with the app itself
we can look at so it's it's kind of an
interesting display here it kind of
reminds me of sort of an old-school sort
of 8-bit game type you know type look
and feel yeah I mean I'm not a big fan
of it though yeah mostly like it just it
feels out of place on Android
yeah it is not hollow I mean if you flip
through here to let you know you have
this sort of fake LCD display but it
doesn't really look like an LCD it looks
like a you know computer-generated yeah
I'd expect to see if you're gonna go for
something this mimicking a real display
ads you know some gloss onto it make it
actually look real
you know who go for that you're gonna go
yeah the the digital look go for the
real look but in between it just looks
sort of mspaint dish to be honest no
that's absolutely true I in fact one of
the first jobs I ever had out of out of
college I was a building software for an
industrial inspection company and
because all of the equipment that they
usually use it's all sort of all school
with the LCD displays and everything and
so I made the software to try and look
as much like that as possible and you'd
find yourself getting into this arms
race where you want it to look just like
the real equipment then you do it first
and you do it like this and everything
is flattened you're like well that's not
quite right because their stuff glows so
how do I make this glow and then you
start adding gradients to your images
and it just goes to a very bad place you
end up spending a lot of time trying to
you know do these little things with
with canvases and everything else to try
and mimic something which is done that
way because it's cheaper to do in
hardware not because it looks better
obviously the inward way of doing things
yeah we tend to not really try and mimic
real displays very often real objects
and that's just sort of that's the hot
this this style we've chosen so an app
like this just feels out of place on the
system I mean ignoring the fact that we
have no action bar I don't know why
there's no action bar we also have the
menu button of shame lisa has a menu so
as shameful but I mean there's there's
no reason that can be converted to it
into an action bar I mean I think the
app would just look a lot nicer with the
splash of holo on there
tomato cream I think what the app
developer is trying to do if you go into
settings you can actually change the
theme so I think they were trying to
make it Thema Bowl you can choose like a
nighttime view or an Amber view or a red
view maybe yeah it's not so bad actually
a few outdoors you know to stargazing
you want a GPS because you're going
hiking you know being able to set you
all right yes there yeah being able to
set a there you go like a knife and I
like that it's actually a pretty good
idea hmm but you know you could do
something like that and still trying to
do through the holo I think I think so I
mean this is again this is you know I
spent a lot of time in a previous life
working on boats you know we have a lot
of this equipment set up and you do you
have nice fun views as soon as the Sun
Goes Down you have this much more muted
theme so people don't destroy their
night vision while
the controls and I kind of like the idea
of making that sort of thing on
something like that but you know part of
me would say well what is the purpose of
your app and so if it is to sort of work
as a backup or as an alternative to some
of these GPS systems while you're
navigating that first I would say it's
probably of questionable utility because
unless you're sitting on the roof of
your boat then you're gonna have this
problem where you don't have any
satellites in view if it's just an
aesthetic thing you're just really
trying to mimic that style because
that's what you used to and you think
that you know your users will sort of
appreciate that that's that's definitely
a choice but I kind of agree with Trevor
here I think you can do that without
making it look like an old Atari game so
you've got the same sort of layout the
same sort of graphics because the big
graphics and these sorts of features are
definitely the right approach but you
just you know want to spend a little bit
more time to think about how you can use
that same layouts but on something which
is much more modern so mimicking a
modern GPS rather than a GPS which you
would have seen in a computer game in
the 80s yeah yeah she brings up another
point a just as far as like the number
of options in here I mean there's a lot
of color schemes which you know not
necessarily a bad thing but just looking
around the entire app you have a ton of
settings
some of which are redundant you have a
an option to use Imperial or metric
units for your your speedometer Imperial
metric units for altitude you know it's
like you could condense all of those
that you just want to think do I want
Imperial or metric instances I can't
think of very many cases where I'd want
my speed in one system and my altitude
in another and you know there are some
other things there too you can choose
between if you go to this menu here you
can actually change all this to gauges
which again has the same problem where
it looks sort of like a tiny name but
just like so many options on here and
your this and honestly as a user yes
it's too much because I'd never find
them all yeah makes it an undiscoverable
right it's like you almost if you want
to be able to choose between different
gauges you may want to do that and then
even going through the options on the
bottom there's you know there's this
mode and this mode and then when you're
in sea
there's another mode here if you go to
navigation and then you have this mode
this mode and then you have it hidden
menu there it's the navigation her key
is very it's a bit difficult to find
especially without textual labels on
those buttons yes so this is really
interesting so I mean it looks like this
app is does a lot of stuff like it's
basically every gauge your dial you
would want which has any very yeah which
yeah I like and and having you know I
really want to make a big point of this
is that when we're sort of discussing
you know changing the UI to make it look
less old-school I really want to
emphasize that I don't think that you
should change the overall layout I love
that it's it's big buttons it's very
graphical you know everything is based
around sort of being able to see it from
a distance I think that's a really good
approach yeah like like I say when it
comes to the mimicking the LCD stuff
like having been there I can tell you
there's really not worth while and the
feedback that you get from most actually
users is yeah that's really hard to read
so it's a lot of effort which which may
not entirely be worth it so it's
something to keep a good question
because Humira know we did from I don't
think I can see us because our camera
isn't glowing but yeah we can't see you
eventually carry a few thoughts on this
place yeah yeah yeah so one thing that
immediately confused me and I agree with
that like the the big the big dial is
the big like I guess panels are awesome
one thing that confused me was a little
bit was about the the interactions
basically you have these these four
panels at the bottom on this is on the
home screen you have these four panels
at the bottom and touching them
basically switches out those you know
the the main display at the very top but
it wasn't clear that that those panels
were kind of like the top level
hierarchy and then above those four
panels those four buttons was kind of
the thing you're currently viewing so I
would try to use some sort of better
visual indication that at the bottom is
kind of like your primary control set
and then at the very top is something
that is a member of that control set
it's not currently visible because you
know touching it they're kind of like
tabs but the current tab is not visible
yeah but somehow indicate that that what
you're viewing at the top is one of the
things
that is you know in this other set of
controls at the bottom and then when you
touch on because the the number is the
one that has heading speed and altitude
you bring up another set of controls
where basically speed out student
heading are kind of a secondary set of
quote-unquote tabs and you can apply the
same visual maybe some sort of like like
arrow indicating that you know the top
screen is a child of the creat of the
you know lower buttons something like
that I don't know if I'm explaining this
very well but I think it's just the
hierarchy isn't clear immediately from
from the current presentation yeah no I
totally agree it's sort of the idea of
this being a toggle but it's not really
a toggle it's just swapping out whatever
the currently selected option is was not
obvious to me either and then similarly
as as Trevor pointed out this
there are basically two modes you've got
navigation mode which has which allows
you to it works a lot like my tracks in
a way it'll let you keep track of
waypoints and where those locations are
which is really really cool but then and
then there's GPS test which is another
version and it's basically two apps with
one within one app and it's not obvious
like when I'm sitting here I think okay
well I want to go back to the other mode
and so I hit back and and that just
exited the app the right way to do it is
to go back into a GPS test from here so
might not be the right name for this
part I think it's so much more than that
we're just trying to build gonna see the
GPS yeah absolutely I mean that's the
thing I can I can almost imagine where
this has come from like you know you
fired up the Android SDK you see all
this cool stuff you can do with GPS and
so you're gonna test all the GPS AP ice
and then you create this app from it but
I almost feel like it's time to move
beyond that in terms of the app name and
try and be a bit more descriptive as to
what it does and and even you know in
terms of your navigation here GPS test
in navigation seemed like two very
different functions they both use the
GPS certainly but in terms of why you're
going to use them they're very different
and I'd be tempted to have reason why I
mean having owned one of the really old
Garmin GPS
this is basically the way the UI works
you turn it on it gave you the GPS
tennis screen would show you all the
staff and satellites and after a while
you get a lock and you switch over to
your Waypoint navigation so like I said
it really does feel like they're
building a proper GPS unit shown on one
of the fancy ones with mapping and
everything coming for your phone yeah
that's it and I mean I think that's a
valid use but on the other hand I'm not
sure you if you're using it like that
actually seeing that screen is too
useful I wasn't sure what to use from
the old GPS unit either really what you
want to know is you know you have an LED
that says is my GPS lock ever read and
then you could click on that and have
that pull up your whole GPS yeah so they
really don't spoil them to you what do
you want this have to do do you want it
to be a GPS test app or you want to take
it to the next level okay I think you
could I think you could actually just
say this is my GPS utility happen yeah
absolutely and you know as far as that
goes that may then control how you
decide to structure your navigation
because I think fundamentally even more
important than the graphics element
which I think I'm quite sure a lot of
people going to disagree with us and be
like no I love the old-school stuff so
it's always subjective exactly what I
think much more important than that is
sorting out the navigation make make it
much clearer where you are in the app
how to move to different parts of it and
make everything work together and I
think figuring out what is the the key
purpose I talked a little bit about this
during my i/o session this year but what
is the focus what is the thing that you
want people to associate your app with
is it oh yeah I want to check to see
what the GPS quality is so I'm going to
use GPS test and fire it up and see
exactly how many satellites are in view
and what the act
accuracy is or do you want it to be like
okay I'm going for a hike or I'm going
fishing and I want to be able to mark
down the best fishing spots or the best
you know hiking trails and so I'm going
to use GPS test navigation to do that
chances are it's going to be one or the
other it's what your users are using or
you know what your direction for the app
is and so I would try and find a way to
focus more on that and make everything
else sort of more supportive of that and
try and really get that focus as tight
as you can and one minor in here add on
to that just a to navigation and streety
oh I think we lost Roman commit well
yeah remember guys when I was uh when I
was crawling around on the floor we do
remember plugging stuff yeah yeah yeah
that's because somebody unplugged the
Chromebook and then used its original
plug to do something else
we have no hangout okay that's just the
way it is
sorry Roman if you can still hear us
somewhere anyway yeah they can't not
speak louder very nice yeah we could
have them join us on G talk on that
thumb there we can switch back and forth
a pin Roman now if I worked or well I
think we're gonna stick with the app for
now yeah well we'll have Roman joining
us again hopefully next week we're gonna
try and continue to keep him involved in
our Friday reviews even though he is all
the way in New York City also gentleman
five minutes excellent all right let's
have a look so we're going to do a quick
community service announcement type type
talk on on one of the apps or a kind of
app which is which we get a lot of
nominations for and that is a virus
checkers oh yes so I can't see but I'm
gonna assume that you put there put
something on screen but so we get a lot
of nominations for virus checking apps
and one of the struggles we have is that
you know if we decide we want to put it
up and talk about it is that it's then
already being removed from market or
from Google Play before we actually get
a chance to look at it so there is kind
of a clue as to where I'm going with
this based on that and the struggle here
is that a lot of the times these apps
they're basically trying to spread fudge
so it's a case of all it's a computer
type thing and I don't want to get a
virus if I want to get malware so I
better download a virus checker to make
sure that that doesn't happen to me the
problem is well I know I'm gonna turn
that around slightly the good news is is
that really isn't something that you
need so you don't need virus checkers
for your Android phones most of the
cases what these apps claim to do isn't
quite legit and so that's why a lot of
these will disappear from Google plays
because they're basically claiming to be
able to do something which they can't
and a lot of that's because they're
already sandboxed and that's a really
part of that security model is that apps
can't mess with other apps
which has the very positive side effect
of meaning that viruses are very very
difficult to create so you know we
certainly have had some small issues
with malware and there's processes in
place to remove those but in terms of
apps infecting other apps interfering
with the way they work you know isn't
really an issue or it's the side effect
of that is of course by the same token
having an app which is supposed to go
through and scan other apps and modify
the way they behave in the way that a
virus checker works doesn't work either
right yeah so yeah there's really you
you can't write a virus checker so if we
see one that sort of immediately raises
a red flag for everyone on the team and
we ask what the heck is this app doing
and most of the time the answer is it's
it's lying to the user exactly and so
even if it's not doing anything
malicious in and of itself which often
they aren't it's simply it's claiming to
do something which you can't do and that
definitely raises flags and to be honest
a lot of the time we've seen situations
where apps like this are just trying to
prey on on people's sort of preconceived
notions of what they need and they also
tend to have a pretty high correlation
of spam within the app description and
so on itself so it's basically for
whatever reason people trying to get
people to download this app and then you
know do advertising things around that
now it's not always the case but that's
that's certainly something which we've
found a lot of so we won't be reviewing
any virus checker apps because as far as
we're concerned the answer is it does
nothing so in case you're wondering
while we see it passed them in the
future
checking okay which I think technically
you could do you can run through the
whole package list and search for
package name and you can't look inside
of it but you could match against known
packages but honestly that's not even
really needed on really bit anymore
because you can just go and click on a
notification and find out that a map it
came from so exactly so it's something
which you know we're definitely very
keen to try and make sure that the
platform is free of anything which is
going to be annoying frustrating and
malicious against users and we will try
and find a ways to do that within the
platform itself because you know quite
simply it's not something that can be
done effectively or even at all in most
cases by a third party
all right so let's have a let's have a
look at what else have we got so we've
got a bunch of notes apps I don't think
we really have enough time to look at
them so let's have a look at run double
instead I'll have a look at will do a
notes app review next week there's
always a lot of notes apps which we get
up for review so I think that's what
we'll do next week is just get like a
whole collection of them we'll go
through the the moderator queue so if
you have a Notes app that you'd like us
to look at probably a good opportunity
to put it into the moderator queue and
we'll we'll run through like a bunch of
them and pick out the best and worst of
each all right so this is uh see what is
the name of this app this is a run
double first comment the UI sort of
hurts my eyes yeah it's a little bright
yeah it is extremely the other question
I had about this and I'm gonna I'm gonna
go ahead and check it also menu buttons
of shame menu buttons of shame that's
true
yeah the the add as well so you know no
problem with having ad supported apps by
any means but the concern here is more
that it kind of looks at a place kind of
like Ian while he's hovering in front of
us you know it really sort of doesn't
quite work with the rest of the UI and
everything feels kind of a little off
balance perfect Thank You Ian see
ourselves again all right so I'm gonna
have a look in the Play Store because I
have a suspicion I'm just gonna slide
this back while I bring up the right app
okay c2fo awesome chat icon yeah it's a
little unfortunate but what I'm almost
more concerned with so what I'm not sure
of here is whether or not this app is
officially sponsored by run double or
this is a an app which someone is built
to help support something by third party
yeah authors inspire run CC 25k exactly
and so that it brings up a question mark
for me and and so this this is
potentially so again I don't know in
this particular case and I try and find
out exactly but if it if it is a run
double app then that's great
yeah it's certainly something we'd like
to see if it's not so this is an app by
someone who's has built something to
support the third party you want to be
really cautious about the way that you
promote that because there are rules in
the Play Store about not creating apps
and app descriptions which make it seem
as though your app is officially
affiliated with something that isn't or
that it is an app that it isn't also
more broadly speaking there's trademark
laws as well absolutely we can't comment
on but there's something you'd be aware
of yeah exactly and so you know even
even leaving the sort of the legal side
aside if the you know if our team looks
at this and and we find out okay no it's
not by the run double team even if you
you know here it isn't clear to me
whether or whether or not that's the
case and so you want to be make sure
that you're really clear to your users
as to is this official is this something
that's in support of another app and
make sure of course that you have
permission from them to use their api's
or their resources in that kind of a way
so we're really conscious about trying
to not confuse users and make sure that
they know exactly what's going on in
here
I'm a little confused so yes that's what
I wanted to that's what I wanted to
check so let's go back into the app so
yeah the the big thing here is that the
UI is it's it's it's too bright yellow
is too much and then you've got the
small icons with the white text again
sort of old-school looking icons which I
mean they're the reasonable resolution
but they're also look very victory so
yeah I definitely work on that like
right now it's not particularly
appealing like just don't make it want
to go away because it's hurting too much
well yeah
this cream there's something I should
point out Tuesday so I think if so oh
she's one screen back so first off here
the change plan which lets you I think
yeah I think if you click something here
it lets you oh it works now it tried to
make me buy it earlier okay I don't know
why even buy it no I didn't so at least
a few minutes ago when I try to do this
I don't even know how to get back there
up creepy ah there we go
so that's nothing that's confusing like
these menus are pretty much the same why
is it and there's three ways to get to
this
you're there there or there there I
should just be one menu but also when
you probably you're looks like the
description says couch to 5k and I click
buy and the description now does not say
anything someone great couch to 5k in
weeks three to nine I guess is sort of
similar but it doesn't match exactly and
hmm that confused me for a second yeah
it's not clear exactly what remaining
weeks three and nine which I guess
implies that this is weeks one two three
and then this must be nine it's all the
same thing yeah yes I'm basically a my
feedback there to make sure that your
in-app descriptions if you doing in that
purchasing earlier whether you're at
your descriptions in your UI match what
you give to market to display in the
project screens yeah absolutely make it
clear so I think what's going on here is
that you can do the couch to 5k as a
free trial for two weeks but if you want
to do the remaining three to nine times
week then you need to do the purchase so
that's you know if you read through it
in detail you can get to where it's
trying to get you to go but you
definitely want to try and make that as
clear as possible you know there's a lot
of text on one screen it is yeah you
never want to be a place like the real
big advantage of you're not billing is
that it removes those barriers it's
fewer clicks between I want this and I
have this so you want to make sure that
that's a smoother passes possibly I
almost like I said every that upgrade
menu and in the change plan button you
know have your have your purchase button
right there and then you can go and gray
these how to figure of a label or if
you're in trial mode you know exactly
what you get so anyways you could go and
improve the purchase flow there and you
know it's an app developers good for you
yeah so okay so don't wanna spend too
much more time on this mainly because
we're pretty much out of time but the
big the the big suggestion I would have
for you here is to basically take
another look at your UI create something
which is less busy
less bright and and sort of less text
more pictures really try it again it's
all about focus trying to figure out
what what is it that I would get this
app to do what are the actions that I
want a user to do once they start this
and bring them to the forefront
everything else you know some of it you
may want to move into menus or move
further down the hierarchy you'll just
remove completely it's really just a
case of figuring out you know what is
that you want me to do once I install
your app and try and drive me down that
part is blinding your users usually not
what you want to do no not safety though
I mean unless that's what your app is
for if your app is called blind me blind
yeah I'm being harsh but I mean yeah
it's just this yellow on black seems a
little much a bit much you know again
like I was saying earlier try and make
it blend in with the rest of the system
take a look at the holo design
guidelines I suspect you're trying to do
some branding here with the own black
thing which is cool
and there are ways to go and keep that
motif going while still staying true to
how hollow is supposed to look and feel
absolutely alright so we're out of time
I want to give in and down from the
Friday and games review a chance to set
up so we're gonna sign off we will be
back next week with hopefully Fred we'll
be back again next week as well and
maybe Trevor will join us too and we're
going to take a look at some note-taking
apps so in the meantime we will bid you
adieu
hopefully you'll stick around and watch
the Friday games review with Ian and Dan
and the mystery hat I'm not sure what
the mystery head is this week but it's
bound to be and excited free beer as
well it's always a mystery B M that's
very true but there's a special mr. beer
oh yeah that's exciting that's right
this time the beer is a mystery to Dan
but I'll give you a preview cuz I doubt
he's watching it's gonna be mckellar as
1000 I give you well we'll see what you
know how much of a hophead
II truly think that how can you turn
that down so we expected all of you guys
we'll take a quick bathroom break and
we'll all be back in ten minutes for the
Friday games review okay thank you for
joining us everyone